[Musica]
nel frattempo si evitare che questi non
cadere l'acqua
quasi nuovissimo avventura assieme
l'ultima avventura natalizia perché oggi
dovremmo stappare dal par tour nel libro
gretel e le comode primo corno cosa
farebbe va bene che sono mangiar mettere
un bel mi piace costa utilizza questo
video la nostra vettura
diego silva mi piace il mio nuovo
cerchietto con tutti più vediamo chi è
dell'anica stories family e ci segue da
tav cannoni nostro video private nei
commenti qual è il primo video in cui ho
fatto vedere questo cerchietto dove l'ho
comprato perché c'è stato un video in
cui ho fatto vedere dove l'ho comprato
prima bozza è infatti anche il mio
avatar
rob lowe al cerchietto con i fiori ma
iniziamo subito questa avventura allora
il grinch equa ha già un aspetto un po
strano un po grigio perché così
l'inserimento passeggiate attraverso le
scatole per distruggerle per trovare la
chiave il grigio dice so di avere la mia
chiave in una di queste scatole sono
troppo pigro ehi tu vai tra le scatole
trova la mia chiave attiva
forse sono qui le altre scatole
marzo è già morta decaduto ti ho fatto
ho sentito la chiave
che bello tutto giornate di natale del
green cosa ci continua a essere un po
strano tutto grigio c'era una volta un
grigio che voleva rubare il natale il
greci viene da nord di gubbio di aver
natale ma ogni anno le campane
iniziavano a suonare
era tempo per il gregge di distruggere
il natale per tutti e rovinare il natale
una volta per tutte l'uomo è bellissimo
questore riscosso diventa non dopo
rimettere mano indietro di
votanti fa il doppio salto
scrittore
ha scritto regali 15 di 12 quindi che
dobbiamo trovare infatti qui vince dice
veloce aiutami a trovare tutti i regali
ma questa è la nostra missione corale di
sali qui sulla slitta che abbiamo solo
un aiuto che rubare il rollover sicali
non sa trovare sembra che tu abbia
attivato gli allarmi cerca di schivare i
laser degli elfi ok ma non dovevamo
recuperare molti regali che cosa ha
fatto accedendo sempre la so come
fighissima queste scheib room con il a
the mission impossible tv guarda se star
di due volte poi che fai
[Applauso]
con questi due volte poi un backup
doppio salto ero wow adoro ma sono un
bel mi piace ancora lasciato sotto
questo video e scrivete sistema ma cosa
farete a natale cosa sperate di ricevere
per natale tf bisogna schivarli aiuto
vitale voleva già a rubare questi regali
degli elfi la musica è sufficiente
sembra di essere in un periodo che sei
la briga di te ero preso di nuovo
distretto troppo devo concentrarmi
vitale non può a superarmi ok ci sono
quasi per così dire ad anela giu
ma invitare i laser
e
non a e divertentissimo room abbiamo
degli altri laser però qui ci sono delle
scatole forze da rompere queste scatole
mano rock vediamo credo di no o forse i
bisogni interni brava ottima idea
un abito io 6 potrei mai avuto sempre
una chiave rossa vero ci servirà per
aprire qualcosa aspetta che ho visto più
niente aspetto mi aspetto che mi sto
perdendo dell'abi rito anch'io è così
ecco tre è uscita
dopo dentro aspetta che il grinch che
dice qualcosa ci sono tre porte devono
essere sbloccate ho sentito che gli elfi
hanno nascosto tre chiavi dentro al
tunnel
quindi vai a cercare nei tunnel per
vedere se trovi le chiavi non c'è
problema uno l'abbiamo già tutto una
volta che le chiavi dentro la porta sei
una libreria
bisogna camminare attraverso la libreria
per trovare alle lettere ok a mio vedere
della visita aprire la porta così si
aspetta un po trovato qualcosa per una
scatola
che succede
io vado a cercare l'altro che ok ma
troviamo affidiamo se lo troviamo sembra
vincente se sia un ventura ecco la
chiave gialla davvero perché per un
momento sono uscita fuori dalle tasche
from dalle mode o che avevo preso la
chiave gialla regione siamo entrare
nella paruta no qua non c'è la porta
quindi la città una bruna eccola dove
quella gialla che quale prezzo apriamo
ecco la chiami tu buona manovra
c'è l'altra libreria qui si ok ci manca
solo la portavano presto robert a
rompiamo le scatole
[Musica]
ecco le lettere stanno andando nella
libreria
che dice presto insegue il grinch
dobbiamo riavere quei regali salvare il
natale venture
e quindi si rischia moltissimo ma è il
grigio fino alla fine gareggia forse e
io stiamo già morta no veramente bisogna
fare la gara di vino polmonare gli
ostacoli del green ce lo vedi no nulla
velocissimo
dobbiamo raggiungerlo evitare gli
ostacoli
no sono sfracellato su un albero nel
primo muterebbe sfracello
se si è sfracellato è troppo di pesce su
fa la slitta del green cielo perché
avete lo vedo più no mi sono speso al
lato di nuovo
posso farcela sono a buon punto no
riproviamo concentrazione devo
massimizzare il girone tacoli ok siamo a
buon punto
i più difficili da evitare sono gli
alberi
ma oggi siamo quarti ma possiamo farcela
mi raccomando fai il doppio stato
ah sì io ho fatto sempre con uno è
riuscito sito prendo anch'io
menomazione no siamo o no io ho fallito
vitale sta continuando provando che qui
non me io provo a fare questo stage
allora forse no ancora una possibilità
vediamo almeno sia veloce lato
non avere neanche iniziato e già ti dico
frase lato il primo tappeto
attento a non cadere giù un i regali
mi raccomando fai intrapreso più alto ok
che frank e corriamo con le mani così
[Musica]
che belli questi colori i questi regali
sono qui sono qui suoi regali e come
tale tease precederà o non si procederà
non so più quella regali scegliere
ok
te ne sei andata viene
fatta cadere a chi ci sono casi arriva e
così no nell'ultimo sei caduta stavo di
arrivarci che schiappa
c'è la prova che mette porta 25 milioni
di battere nel frattempo io sono
invecchiato ma c'è un mini babbo natale
che cosa non ho bisogno del tuo aiuto
cerca di ottenere attraverso la slitta
ed evitare i regali che stanno cadendo
voglio danneggiare nessun regalo ora
vero è nato insieme sono i regali tutti
rotti a questo tipo il fabbricato
obbligano tutti gli eletti che li sta
impacchettando il preparato consultare
sul ricambio era il contrario dovevamo
evitare il real wow ma è bellissimo
estrogeno propri casi reali
mi trasportino sono caduto dal rullo
wow fuori di mortai e dove sto finendo
nero slitta davvero se riuscita
più bravo eccovi mai arrivato così a
babbo natale che fatto nomi
sorridente e felice e quindi abbiamo
vinto
nonostante
sbrigati non riescono dobbiamo andare
traverso i cerchi media quindi bisogna
tipo guidare la slitta
ok ora vedo meglio che ok ok bisogna
cliccare basta tenere premuto
bellissimo
anch'io ho preso uno ed emergere a
centrarli ma perché non ti hanno dato la
patente della slitta forse per quello io
vedo evitare che volatilità come dove
morì senza
slittava è troppo difficile
allora sto informando se ce l'ho fatta
un nome sbattere contro un albero devo
rifare tutto daccapo fallito
ci sta riprovando allora non possiamo
regionali qua non mi dire che deve
entrare in tutti c'è
mi sa di sì
noi ne abbiamo fatti due per il momento
ce ne sono tipo 150k ok ho preso uno
dall'altro non presenta no tav ha
sbattuto sulle rocce che riproviamo
ok e ci sono riuscito a passare il primo
vecchio ok forse forse sì storici dopo
perché ogni non udenti non ha un'altra
parte
e quanti cerchi preso 2 ma poi ogni
senso pd non vogliono quasi presi tutti
e quasi ci siamo quasi forte del mio
motto è stato difficili dai contesti
anche questo e quello verde di
via
capisco contro un altro fatto
sempre capitale morto
no è che ha fatto uno spuntino e mi sono
addormentato nel frattempo chiarito
guidava la slitta
[Risate]
[Musica]
ok vai dai guai troppo bella questo è
pronto il rum davvero divertenti alla
fine del video che vede si nei commenti
che ho avuto gli date da 1 a 10 chiamo
praticamente nell'albero cioè sul bacio
nella notte si supera l'albero di qua ci
sono le scale le scale i rami e farmi
che fanno da scala giro famiglia l'altro
natale che abbiamo fatto se non lo avete
visto andate a vederla perché io un po
difficile perché questi rami sono troppo
sottili e che dice casa facilmente ok
bisogna andare piano
vitale che cadeva pure pure a vita cade
però resta la parte più difficile
tuttavia che i prof prendere la mia più
che altro dove atterrare nov papa
contenuto questo albero lari siria
mumbai a tradirlo tour allora se siamo
arrivati massimo fino al quarto ramo
partiamo faccia forse entro domani
riusciamo firma poi ci sono anche le
palline di natale
wow bravo su troppo bravo
modo si sbroda che forse ora è più
semplice perché c'è questa parte del
ramo chiamano piano piano sono arrivato
che qualcuno possa cadere adesso
dove salta adesso proviamo qua
wow stiamo in alto ei falso io continua
a cadere sempre in basso mi raccomando
doppia stato io mi sono salvata per un
pelo con il doppio salto che questo è
difficilissimo guardate quante lontano
sei riuscita l'ultimo ramo non posso
credere che lui singolo ramo nel
frattempo si evitare che questi non
cadere l'acqua
non arrivare quando termina spettacolo
di vita che per ingraziare
oppure tentare il mio ultimo bravo
ce ne facciamo
bravissima entriamo stupita da evitavano
parti ma contiamo di terra state un mi
piace per portare fortuna a evitare poi
di superare questo stage lasciate mi
piace qui sotto per portargli mortara
povero vitale ancora bloccato limi
robbie allora in cosa specie se un elfo
che dice suggerimento per ordinare il
pacchetto è solo ordina a mi ha dato un
pacco regalo forse devo ammetterlo sto
correndo velocissimo
un'altra corsa forse lo devo portare
subito alla slitta non lo so la fabbrica
riproviamo
comunque è bellissimo ma ne raccontano
lo sai che ho trovato un trucchetto per
superarlo velocemente sei riuscito
sinora mi bastava bastava andare
praticamente vicino al ramo vicino al
tronco e fare un sugo salto e quindi
sono riuscito il brano che facilissimo
corriamo corriamo
congratulazione riusciva a e vito lo
capo che
aspettiamo evitare nel frattempo devo
prendere un bel sole e mezzo grazie per
aver salvato il natale però vediamo se
c'è qualche bacio nascosto qua mentre
aspettiamo vitale
come corri detto lei poco regale ve lo
devo prendere
passiamo un baby piace e
avellino a cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video su quella che
preferite